je serais pas un peu trop lesbiennes
tuer les oueds et chaud pas que ce soit
trop flagrant surtout vers toi ok j'ai
un score pour le visage une bouteille de
scotch une recette de gâteau et un cube
pour fabriquer des bijoux
tu peux rester là cette nuit ouais c'est
la seule personne que je supporte on est
fiché salut sacha moi c'est une qui m'a
pas dit qu team serait là c'est sûr que
j'ai suivi à des mineurs parfois si tu
m'avais prévenu j'aurais mis autre chose
que mon pantalon de pyjama qui un trou
j'ai l'impression qu'ici à trois
portiques de sécurité
les écoles sont pas terribles ici tous
les gamins qui vont dans le privé
deviennent des conservateurs coincée du
cul si metal et d'en priver je suis un
conservateur mois ci du cul c'est pas
vrai
ce plein dit pas qui est en train
d'arriver parce que je suis absolument
pas prête
justement qui m'a fait une surprise il
veut m'emmener dîner dans un restaurant
pour fêter ma victoire
trop mignon que satan nuit si on regarde
tout modèle à un autre soit
figurent cinq ans est fier le groupe est
sur ces témoins et c'est de la chanson
en fait elles se détestent parce
qu'elles sont toutes les deux latinos un
social ce ton genre de films jeux via
steam que tu étais sorti avec une
cubaine restaurants et bars j'ai eu un
radis des chaussures je suis désolé
c'est un jeu d'enfant sait lire
j'ai finit par gâcher ma vie faire des
crises de panique j'aurais dû me douter
que le jour où tu te mettrai en gupta
aurait plus besoin de moi
c'est vrai je suis moins disponibles
pour toi tu ne l'était avant quand je
n'avais personne d'autre que toi dans
menu encore quelqu'un à qui parler
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin rien n'a
changé pour toi c'est pour moi que ça a
changé est ce que tu veux bien au moins
la tête ces bombes attentes
laisse ton dénombre 6 toujours là on est
toujours les deux seuls et se trouvait
drôle
je crois que tim risque d'être jaloux de
mon costard